they happen abandon myself thank you
okay Ross what do you think of Evangelic
Allah give Trump a mulligan for his
behavior that is otherwise condemned G
III don't think don't think well of them
no I mean I think there are two
evangelical styles there sort of I kind
of there's an evangelical style that
says we always knew he was a bad guy
we were just voting for him because he
wasn't Hillary and we needed basically
like a tough guy a bodyguard because we
lost the culture wars and that I can
worry right and that yeah and that that
I can at least understand and but then
there's the other style that's like you
know Trump he's like you know he's like
King David King David had a lot of wives
you know that's just sort of he were but
don't you worry about how important
Jerusalem is in that well that's right I
really believe that a lot of the
Evangelic alieve that Jesus is coming
back many of them in their lifetime
because he's gonna want to meet them
he's gonna want to meet you too he's a
fictional character but I'll be happy to
beat him
I'll probably do the trick for you all
right so do you think the conviction of
Bill Cosby will lead to more celebrity
trials celebrity trials it meaning like
[Laughter]
what's really important about these
cases the Cosby case and the you know
whatever is going on in the subsequent
investigation of Harvey Weinstein is
that we really do need to make a clear
division as Ronan said earlier in the
show between the fact that there are
people who have committed serious
felonious offences and should be taken
in front not only the court of public
hearing with the court of law
as opposed to people whose behavior is
disreputable but not illegal and part of
the problem in the early part of the me2
movement I think was that there was a
blending of the two after you committed
you know criminal offenses definitely
should be treated to criminal court and
that's the only place you get due
process all this other is like screaming
and yelling about whoever got didn't you
to process you know Al Franken didn't
get due process Matt Lauer didn't get
due process Mark Halperin didn't get due
process there's no due process for
losing a job or Mark Halperin
unfortunately yes I really really well
reporting can lead to Criminal Procedure
exact orders but it can happen in tandem
in that way and I would just say in the
Weinstein reporting one thing that was
really important about the Cosby
precedent is in a world in which most
women could never envision taking this
risk speaking out against a powerful guy
and actually being heard saying hey look
at these women who came forward against
Bill Cosby even though they were smeared
they were covered their stories were
sorta kind of heard that was a hugely
important precedent to tell them about I
think we err on the side of listening to
women and not believe all women that's
not
saying no one says that but listening to
women letting women speak and finding
out if they're telling the truth using
reporting to find out more I mean that's
the way you like lump there al Frank and
you in the same sentence with Matt Lauer
and somebody else and it just bugs
Marcus yeah cuz it just I just don't
think Mark Halperin and Al Franken are
the same guy I really just their job
which is a bad thing but it's not like a
lifetime tragedy like I've lost lots of
jobs quite frankly I think pretty big
tragedy for the Democratic Party to lose
a leader like that right thing to do I'm
Al Franken I voted for Al Franken but I
didn't know these things about him if he
were I still don't know those things I
know what a few people said you know
there's you know as how I think I said
there's a picture alone was enough for
me to like reconsider my vote the
picture was justice really that you
can't get by the picture you know that
the one where he's doing that yeah you
know what I can't get it really I got
that's it that somebody should lose his
Senate job for the protective actually
lose a Senate job for that we should
hold those people to higher account but
he was a comedian at the time he's it's
just it's a really electing Trump
certainly has to make all this so much
more raw yeah so much stronger because
when the person who is in the highest
office has obviously not only gotten
away with all the stuff over the course
was life but also clearly treats women
as objects as ornaments it's horrifying
to watch and I think that that's one of
the reasons why people have just gotten
so incredibly angry in in rightful
backlash can I just say one of the most
common things I hear from survivors of
sexual violence when they hear debates
like this which are smart debates and
very fair on all of that the survivors
the people with the actual stories get
lost because we have headline after
headline about these men and we're not
listening to the women and sometimes men
as well who actually endured the
mistreatment but focused
conversation their most victims of
sexual violence aren't famous and the
people that commit those acts aren't
famous and it's in if those are the
people that we really need be paying
attention to it's rampant in service
industries it's rampant yeah you know in
restaurant industry in a hotel industry
and this is something that I I'm glad we
sort of transitioned from the me to to
the time's up movement in a matter of
fact I kind of want to start using that
more that the time's up for everyone and
it's a mintue okay
the entire you wrote the entire business
model of Facebook undermines liberal
democracy how can we stop that model I I
think it's almost impossible to stop
that model because it is the for me the
definition of dystopia is that citizens
get their information about the world as
determined by the world's largest
advertising company and I I mean as much
an interesting way to put it I'm on it
the world's largest advertising company
yeah right
and and I I mean I think as it would
mark zuckerberg said I had no idea that
this was gonna happen
I actually believed him I think he had
no idea because he didn't want to look
into it because he was talking his book
which is I've got a model we need to
build money fiduciary responsibility
that's the way it's gonna be but it is
very clear that if all the things that
we've talked about that are ripping a
part of the fabric of liberal democracy
nothing is doing it faster than
technology everyday that's behind fake
news that's behind you know sort of us
versus them that's behind everything
that makes us not want to have civic
nationalism and common values and
there's nothing that makes me believe
that we're moving away from that but you
don't want I mean I I've read part of
your book and I think I agree with it
generally but I think one of the
strengths of your book is that it's not
just about sort of I mean I I think
there's a tendency for people who are
sort of associated with the
establishment in the West to want to pin
everything on Facebook and fake news and
social media and so on when the reality
is that
you know the reason people believe
conspiracy theories and fake news and
all the rest is that the people running
the west you know the the the globalists
to use to use your language has had a
really terrible track record over the
last 15 years and I mean the biggest
threat to liberal democracy in certain
ways is the fact that we had the Iraq
war a global financial crisis you know a
sort of totally terribly designed euro
zone that led to all sorts of economic
problems that were totally foreseeable
but none of the people paid to foresee
them for saw them and so on and I mean
in that sense I think this the strongest
part of your argument is about the
people in charge not the bronze bull I
really appreciate that and obviously I
agree with it but I think the thing that
everyone should know but I think the
thing that my book that's really been
turned on its head is the 25 years when
we started the internet it was all about
on the internet no one knows if you're a
dog right it was empowering like Tunisia
Egypt
those things happen in Department now
everyone knows your dog on the internet
it doesn't empower people but we went
from this ludicrous techno optimism
where this was going to liberate
everybody and save civilization and now
it's destroying civilization and we
never went through the period in which
it's like it's got good parts and it's
got bad parts and maybe we can emphasize
the good things and downgrade the bad
things I mean I tell you know wish
steven pinker here was to make to make
the case you know that he makes that
actually we look at the bad part of it
but look at for example how many people
have been lifted out of extreme poverty
probably a lot earlier globalism in the
last 20-30 years how many a billion a
billion out of poverty and it's happened
before in the history of mankind
I'm optimistic in terms of the global
most macro view it's a pretty good time
to be a lot of thinker in the world in
general right less violence I mean but
but the Astros worse in the United
States we have our life expectancy going
down here equality is growing here and
life expectancy between the racists as
well
opening that what's coming and suppose
the United States is increasingly China
a country that is authoritarian that
uses technology top-down and much poor
right and as a consequence I'm much more
concerned about a world led by that than
I am about a world that habit limit and
we're eviscerating our capacity to go
toe-to-toe about that but that's
reversible so that's reversible and all
I'm saying is the only if we fund the
state to say it's reversible it may not
be reversible this month by the book or
this year but first yeah we'll do it all
but you're gonna get the last question
how would you stop the West from
committing what you call cultural
suicide well first thing should by and I
have books out of print bill has a novel
called true yes no one reads books
anymore okay but I would say right that
part of it is that we don't tell
ourselves we don't tell ourselves in the
West that we are inheritors of a great
patrimony that we have a wonderful great
liberal tradition we we all we do is we
most elites and most of the public
discussion is about everything that's
wrong it's important to highlight things
that are wrong so that they can be
changed but we have no cultural respect
for station about it the fact that we
live in a time of extraordinary growth
and extraordinary opportunity and you
know China is is a danger and a threat
China also is a country that has no
ideological hold on anybody it can't
preach it's got nothing to preach it's
just a different and it can't breathe
and it can Anna can't breathe and what
good is dry ganking America curity a
problem in the next 10 years with like
350 million people meeting right you
know aid and relief and there's no money
for it and so I think if we think more
positively I mean it sounds like
sounds a name I would say that's all
true except that I just think the
environmental iceberg is what's melting
and that's what's gonna get us goodnight
everybody
[Applause]